here buddy welcome back to another
episode of awesome build where today
we're gonna take a look back at what
went into making the stop-motion
animated nostalgia ween opening we did a
few years ago we'll look a little bit
into how I'd made the puppets how we
constructed the sets and a little bit on
how I did the actual stop-motion
animation so I have some footage that I
shot a few years ago that originally it
was going to be put I think on one of
the DVDs as an extra but I'm not sure I
actually ever made it on one of the DVDs
so I'll share it with you guys today
Halloween is right around the corner
again and as we're going into nostalgia
me next week I thought it'd be kind of
cool to take a look back at how we did
that opening sequence it's personally
one of my favorite projects that I ever
worked on here at channel awesome when
Doug first approached me about it I
think it was only about two weeks before
he needed the footage and he called me
he's like I have a crazy idea I'm not
sure that you're really gonna have time
to do it but if there is I think would
be great he was like but I wanted to
call you and talk to you about it first
and see if it was something that we
could do and if we could we have time
and all that kind of stuff
he knew that I was into stop-motion and
I had done a little bit of stop-motion
before I had some of my puppets and
stuff like that lying around the studio
and he said he wanted to do a parody of
The Nightmare Before Christmas and I
think before he even finished his
sentence I was like yes absolutely we
have time to do it but we can do it even
at the time I was kind of like I don't
know necessarily how it's all gonna turn
out or what's all gonna go into it but I
can't pass up this opportunity
I love the neighbor before Christmas and
anytime I get an opportunity to do
stop-motion I jump on it so I really
couldn't pass it up but I knew it was
gonna be pretty challenging given the
the time constraints that we had I knew
that I was gonna have to construct the
puppets and do the animation in about
two weeks and in addition to some of the
other things that were going on yeah so
I enlisted to help Barney and Rob and I
just kind of worked on the puppets and
they built the set and the animation we
can we didn't got too
days yeah as soon as I constructed the
Skellington puppet I started shooting
some animation as kind of a test
animation and that actually wound up
being a good portion of the walk cycle
that we used in the animation and then
you spent a whole day basically shooting
this the whole sequence where he walks
up to the door opens the door and then
the Pennywise comes out and shoots him
so I hope you guys enjoyed this little
look back at how he kind of did some of
that animation how we built the puppets
and I also have my original cut included
at the end that I presented to Doug
about a day before it was supposed to go
up
you
hey we're here at channel awesome
studios right now we're in the workshop
art department I guess so yeah how about
people have actually been really curious
about how we did the stop-motion
animation for the opening sequence and
nostalgia ween episodes I thought it
would be kind of fun guys a little bit
behind the scenes show how we did it and
yeah okay well here is the Doug
Skellington puppet it's about 12 inches
tall the armature is made out of thin
gauge aluminum wire that I then covered
with a thin aluminum tubing to give it
sort of you can keep the shape but it
still bends just jointed the way it
would be in any sort of normal person I
guess and the heads are the only things
I really sculpted the head removes as
you can see I've got some replacement
heads and yeah just pops on and so he
has a different expressions and the the
suit I kind of cheated I meet it all on
duct tape I wanted to get you nice to be
very thin and everything and I wanted to
keep that very sleek kind of look and I
had some black and white duct tape and
so I thought I'd sure his so he's got a
white duct tape shirt
duct tape suit as I had to build it fast
yeah I'll get little things like the tie
is actually duct tape to that I painted
red and there's a wire in it so that I
could animate the tie too but that's
basically it I'll show you a little
armature to kind of give you an idea of
what it looks like before I covered it
up
but the heads themselves I sculpted with
white sculpey just the Skokie original
basically and I kept the original shape
once I I wanted the original color once
I fired it in the oven I kind of gave it
that sort of almost bone kind of color
used a really thin mixture of paint and
ink to get the details kind of
highlighted and paint the eyes and stuff
like that yeah that's about it first a
little hat to that kind of I could
switching between puppets but the way I
made the clown puppet is a little bit
different
I'll show you guys here's the Pennywise
puppet I mean essentially it's it's
constructed the exact same way is the
Doug Skellington puppet in fact there's
a wire armature here this is how all the
puppets kind of look like this
underneath I've got a just the thin
gauge aluminum wire I've got it doubled
up and covered with this aluminum tubing
the fingers are made out of like a thin
copper wire essentially does you can get
it any hardware or half as well but yeah
this is just like a plumber's putty or
you can use any kind of like two-part
epoxy that kind of holds everything
together
you don't wanna use too much of it
because you want to keep the overall
weight of your puppet kind of low so
with the penny wise puppet and and most
stop-motion puppets you have your mounts
for the puppet in the bottom of the foot
so you have a little nut in there that
you can shoot a screw in so then the
puppet makes a you know placement on the
stage you shoot a hole through the stage
tie it down with a screw and then move
the like
puppet for the next you know step shoot
a hole through your stage tie it down
the screw so the puppet has to be able
to hold its entire weight for a lot of
filming on just one foot a lot of times
especially if it's making a a step or a
leap or something so you have to make
sure that you keep the weight of your
puppet pretty low that's why I use
usually aluminum is really lightweight I
cover the puppet yeah this one anyway
with the couch cushion foam as I said
earlier I it's got a really crudely made
costume it's scraps of other bits in
fact funny thing about the all the
yellow kind of parts of the costume was
I I didn't have any yellow material so I
took the bumblebee transformers
Halloween costume that we had left over
from demo reel and found the the
yellowest bits of fabric and cut it out
and essentially just glued it to the
falls so so that's how that was made the
difference kind of with this puppet as
opposed to the Jack puppet the Jack when
I made our dog I should say the dogs
going to it was made with several
replacement heads with different
expressions this one because he was
basically I wanted to pop out and he
does the laughs I wanted to animate that
so how I made this one as I sculpted the
face out of sculpey and made a mold and
pour the mold for the kwid latex in the
mold and peel it off and basically got a
mask and just put the mask over a scout
like a basically a head that I had
sculpted to keep the retain the shape
and then underneath the jaw just cut it
in half and the jaw is just a piece of
sculpted epoxy with some wire so that I
could open the mouth and close the mouth
and an animated you know frame by frame
so yeah that's about I add a little
mount here in case the the face broke or
something like that and I didn't want to
remake an entire puppet so I just made a
little knot so I could pop the head back
on and if I needed to change the face I
could but it's still fully articulate he
turns his head and up and down and all
that jazz and mouth so pretty cool now
initially I thought I was gonna have to
do the entire thing green-screen
so Barney and Rob Walker actually they
built that set that you see with the
trees and stuff like that and I had some
cardboard tubing so what Barney did was
he took the cardboard tubing and cut it
up and covered it with the stuff called
Durham's rock-hard putty and he was
covered they basically just one half
because we weren't gonna see if we get
us anyway all these cardboard tubes and
then just ran streaks down it when it
hardened it had this awesome texture
that was like like tree bark and then he
also made the little symbols you know
for the different seasons and went over
the little cartouche is here and Rob
came in and painted it and gave it that
tree kind of look that dark kind of
quality that was sort of very yeah name
it before Christmas Rob then also
painted that whole state like the the
actual stage that we shot it on that was
all Rob too and next year it's kind of
neat about the trees we've made them in
several different sizes to give a sort
of different perspective feel so yeah I
got the the the large tree we actually
we had to make a door so that the cloud
steps out yeah so this is the door that
that Barney made or the buzz does sort
of close up of the tree
what we did is it's basically the same
thing is just a larger piece of the
cardboard tube the back cut out so that
I could animate the puppet from within
and once he covered it in the dirhams
he cut out the door and I put a little
hinge on it so that we could you know
that pop it opens up and comes out of
that the tree here and as I said before
like yeah and Barney made that all the
symbol of the cartouche is whatever and
Rob did a beautiful job of painting
these in me I think oh no I mean it came
out beautifully I thought it looked
great I was so happy that we could do it
on a with a real stage we got a real set
pieces I made all the difference
great job guys okay well this is
basically a mesh how we animated the
Doug Skellington walk sequence when he's
watching the forest looking around I
didn't want to have to build a stage
that was super long or a friend to walk
through it I thought it'd be easier if I
just showed all green screen and put it
in the background and then I could shoot
him stationary and just move him as if
he's walking
if this green screen sort of staged that
I built with this bracket with just a
piece of threaded rod that I can adjust
to whatever height the puppet is and I
put him out on the back of this Doug
puppet and then this way he stays in one
spot but I animated him as though he's
walking and move on
gather wait take a picture move away
take a picture do that essentially 24
times per second 24 frames a second kind
of cheated a little bit because we were
sort of strapped for time so it was kind
of an old trick basically shut this one
was 12 images per second so we doubled
up the amount of images so then it still
has the 24 frames but that's all quiet
looked a little bit tricky not as smooth
and this one was this a little bit
different than the clown puppet because
as I said with that one you guys screw
hole through the bottom of the stage
lock it down with the screw
there's another foot with the Doug
puppet are the feet were so small that I
really couldn't put him out in the
bottom of it anyway
by the time I got done doing the wash
cycle his leg broke and so this is
essentially I had a rapport replace this
leg was just a piece of rod that I bent
into a lake shape and I did put a nut in
this foot and locked it down for that
whole sequence when he opens the door
and gets shot if you notice this but
never leaves the ground because this is
the foot that was holding him up I
didn't want to have to put the rod in
for that sequence because we actually
built a stage for that and I don't want
have to erase the rod I know that it
were a huge pain on maybe chef yeah it
would have been possible to really do
because the rod would have been blocking
part of the stage yeah that's a little
bit I guess the behind-the-scenes how we
did this how I generally most that
motion is done all right guys well I
hope you enjoyed this little look back
at what went into making that
stop-motion intro for the nostalgia we a
few years ago and don't forget to leave
a comment and what do you do see me
build for Halloween I've gotten lots of
great suggestions so far don't forget to
look me up on Facebook at James Jim J
Roz and yeah until next time thanks so
much again take care guys
[Music]